women's Chess World Championship is
underway and the first game in a series
of 12 is played with 97.8 percent
accuracy the Challenger Lei Ting Jae
started with the white pieces against
current champion Zhu in June the game
began with a well-prepared Roy Lopez
with both players blitzing out the first
10 moves by move 11 the players had more
time on their clock than when they
started lay was particularly well
prepped not spending any significant
time until move 19 Zhu teased the
possibility of an early draw with the
repetition but lay chose to fight on
with the bishop pair in the middle game
engine-like Precision from both players
continued without either player ever
gaining any tangible Advantage the game
settled into a drawn rookane game and a
draw was agreed upon on move 50 and with
that